where are our eyeballs at ears going
that to me is the thing that I'm
completely obsessed with right now where
are we spending our time it's a ten
ships and it's definitely caught my
attention I'm paying very close
attention has really caught my attention
but that would have caught my attention
caught my attention at ver Marco Polo
caught my attention and so musically
caught my attention snapchat caught my
attention what I think I'm really good
at is behind them selling I did that
what stuff my whole life now I do it
with people's attention and the end
consumers attention so when people were
listening to the radio people that
wanted to sell stuff marketers realized
they're paying attention to the radio
why don't I stop what they're listening
to and because they're baseball fans let
me sell them this a beer and tell them I
were the best beer ever and interrupt
them and that process my friends has
gone on forever and ever you can go back
to the caves
right here's a cave I use it because I
don't want to get eaten by a dinosaur
and some dude wants to sell me a new
club and he's through some [ __ ] in there
to sell me so while my attention was
here staying away from the dinosaurs I
maybe I need a new club that long and
that forever wherever there are people
paying attention to something marketers
like myself want to ruin it
you